[Music]
[Laughter]
i love the quote
stay in a learner's mind because
curiosity breeds
the desire to explore and to learn and
youtube is a fantastic resource for
exploring different subjects
and ramping up on them especially since
the tech sector is constantly evolving
i think one of the things that is really
unique about tech in general
is that it's so easy to move between
roles and between paths and that can be
both in terms of the role that you do so
whether you are an engineer or product
manager or a designer
but it can also be to move between
verticals right so whether you work on
search or whether you work on video or
whether you work on
machine learning products or ux heavy
products and so i would say
you know optimize for learning and
optimize for what excites you
and i think there's no such thing as
closing a door right so there's always
opportunities to return to a career path
um that you like there's always
opportunities to explore something new
and every career path you choose opens
up a new door
there is so many careers in technology
that haven't even
been created yet i came into google
in a job that didn't exist i was the
first art director
on android i my one of my some of my
first jobs were hiring illustrators to
create beautiful artwork for google play
that type of role it never existed let
your curiosity
lead you even if your side passion might
be
in the arts or humanities space allow
that to
infuse what you end up doing in
technology
um so if you're considering uh different
career paths and tech
i would definitely recommend thinking
about you know what really excites you
what really gets your energy going and
kind of matching that up with where your
skill sets lie
it depends on which stage of career you
are in
if you are a student try to get
different internships and
try something hands-on to see if you
like it
talk to people in those industries about
what their day-to-day work looks like
see if you can shadow some of them see
if you can
do some volunteering work in that
capacity for somebody
and get some hands-on experience to
figure out
if this is something that you would
enjoy doing for the long term explore
explore explore do not stop exploring
you will find that you can match your
current skills with your passion
and really create your own unique path
intact that you love
[Music]
[Music]
you